Oh
Oh
specifically issues of things like gay
rights I mean do you visit bronze it
does he bother you as a Republican do
you think it's what is your take on him
of like gay get give the gay is the
equal benefits on the Constitution you
can call it Super Tuesday to the esta
potty here's your certificate as long as
they have equal rights as far as you any
any married couple yeah it has and like
as an out gay man what you you don't
have any reservations about supporting
the Republican attic no not at all
because I think they I have reservations
as a whole but good or the total package
the entire know if I was like that I'd
fall into the trap of like a lot of duty
people who care tell me who to vote for
based on one tiny issue and yeah I cast
my vote my phone is precious to me and I
have
I have zero reservation are you a union
guy too oh so you said you get voted for
the ball back yes I know and you don't
and you bet your room now voting for
whom i'm going for scott brown typically
i voted i voted republican a lot and not
democrat but I think right now we need
to vote for the best person everybody
that's right for the country today that
Scott Brown and what's the issue that
that most concerns whistle musicians
health care is a big issue that we can't
afford it we can't afford to give it to
people who are here illegally
Oh